اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه الخاصه
بالاحداث في الولايات المتحده حيث توقفت
حركه الطيران المدني في امريكا بسبب عطل
تقني وذلك وفق ما اشارت اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه حيث تم وقف جميع الرحلات في
كافه انحاء البلاد بتاجيل 70060 رحله
داخله وخارج الولايات المتحده والغاء 91
كما قالت ادارته الطيران الفيدراليه ان
العمل جار على اصلاح خلل الفني لاستعاده
حركه الطيران اداره الطيران الفيدراليه
مشاهدينا قالت ان السعاده
الجويه ومراسه العربيه اكدت ان وزير
المواصلات الامريكيه وجهها بالتحقيق بسبب
العطل الفني بحركه الطيران باداره الطيران
ايضا تطلب تاخيره كل الرحلات الجويه حتى
الساعه الرابعه عشر بتوقيت جرينتش على
الاقل بسبب عطل حتى الان
مشاهدينا تنضم الينا من مطار ريجن في
واشنطن مراسله العربيه لتسليمه اهلا
بكريتها ما حقيقه الوضع في المطارات
الامريكيه ريتا
اكثر في جميع انحاء الولايات المتحده صباح
اليوم الاربعاء بعد فشل نظام كمبيوتر رئيس
تابع لاداره طيران الخدراليه
عن تويتر
عبر النظام المجال الجوي الوطني
همم كتبت يعني اداره طيران الفيدراليه لان
العمليات عبر النظام المجال الجوي الوطني
تتاثر بالارقام اعتبارا من الساعه السابعه
و20 دقيقه صباحا بالتوقيت الشرقي هنا في
الولايات المتحده كان هناك 1230 اخيرا
للرحلات داخل الولايات المتحده همم وفقا
لبيانات همم اداره الطيران طبعا كان هناك
ايضا
108 حالات الغاء للرحلات داخل الولايات
المتحده همم ايضا همم هذا النظام
يوفر المعلومات اللي همم الطيارين معلومات
مهمه بشان التغييرات التي قد تؤثر على
رحلاتهم قد يشمل ذلك ايضا اغلاق
سيارات الاجره همم المطارات او حتى وجود
معدات بالقرب من المدرج همم وفقا همم
وسائل الاعلام المحليه هنا ايضا كما نود
ان نشيل بان وزير همم
المواصلات الامريكيه واجهت ب بدء التحقيق
الفوري بسبب هذا العطل الذي حصل اليوم
والذي اثر المطارات اا في في الولايات
المتحده
هل يعد سابقه هل تكرر ولو بشكل جزئين من
قبل في تاريخ الولايات المتحده في احد هذه
المطارات مثلا وانه سابقه
كلها على الاقل همم
لم يصدق ان حصل ذلك من قبل
النظام قد تعطل وخاصه الولايات المتحده
تسدد على سلامه الطيران
وتركز على همم على هذا الامر في شده
تعطلت 1000 12 حوالي 12000 رحله حتى الان
الولايات المتحده هذا هذا سابقا في هذه في
في هذا المجال طبعا
الاوضاع في المطارات من حيث تواجد
المسافرين همم هل كان هناك تقبل هل هناك
تفهم من المسافرين لما يحدث الان امن هناك
حاله من الغضب ربما
والفوضى التي ربما تطال جميع المطارات في
الولايات المتحده
هناك غضب لن تاخر الرحلات بالطبع خاصه
كان هناك مثل همم ازمه ولون
نسبتها قليله ما حصل في
الفتره عيد الميلاد وراس السنه هنا في
الولايات المتحده كان هناك الغاء عدد من
الطيران
الطائرات خاصه شركه طيران واحده على الاقل
فشلت في تامين الطائرات للركاب وهذا اثار
الغضب اليوم هناك تاثير همم وخوف من انه
يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على السلامه المواطنين
المتفاهمون اكثر حول هذا الموضوع صوره
الاقمار الصناعيه ريتا تظهر همم
همم هناك كثافه في حركه الطيران فوق
الولايات المتحده هذا يعني ان هناك رحلات
ما زالت همم في الجو حتى هذه اللحظه
في الجو في هذه الحاله ما مدى يعني القدره
على التحكم في سلامه الطيران هل هناك
معلومات اذا ما كانت تواصل معهم ممكنا في
حال وجود هذا العطل
عدم همم
ولكن همم الامر يتعلق بالسلامه سلامه
طبعا امرت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه
الشركات
الطيران بايقاف جميع الرحلات حتى الساعه
9:00 صباحا هنا بالتوقيت الشرقي لسماح
للوكاله بالتحقق من سلامه معلومات الطيران
والسلام اذا التحقق من سلامه هذه
المعلومات جاري حتى اللحظه
وجميع الرحلات
من السبب الذي ادى الى هذا الخلاء
المشاهدين الى ضيفنا السيد ايهاب عباس
اهلا ايهاب همم ما تعليق البدايه على ما
يحدث في الولايات المتحده هذا العطل هل
همم هو همم امر طبيعي يحدث انه هناك ربما
ايضا خفيه وراء هذا العمل ربما يكون عبر
متعمدا
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين كل
النتائج ااا مفتوحه على مصر عليها طبقا
للتحقيقات التي تجرى الان انه واضح
للمشاهدين ان هذا
السيستم او هذا النظامز هو نظام يقوم
باعطاء كافه المعلومات لشركات السيارات
والقائدي الطائرات طبعا المتعلقه بارتفاع
الطائره سرعتها واا
اتجاهها بايضا لطائرات المحيطه بالطائره
التي تحصل على هذه البيانات
ويقدم ايضا معلومات مهمه جدا اثناء عمليه
الهبوط والاقلاع لانه يحدد ما ارتفاع
الطائره الحقيقي من الارض طب للضغط الجوي
في محيط مكان مدرج الهبوط او الاقلاع وهذه
معلومات خطيره ومهمه جدا لذلك طلب من همم
بعض الرحلات التي هي موجوده في اماكن همم
لديها همم فوق او همم يعني ضباب بعدم
النزول في المطارات التي من المفترض ان
تكون هي الوجه الاخيره لهذه الطائره حتى
التاكد من الارتفاعات الصحيحه وربما اصلاح
العطله ما نعلمه حتى الان ان اف اي اي او
كانت همم الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه
بت تنزيل برنامج نقطه من جديد عبر الاجهزه
الرئيسيه لديها في الوكاله ومحاوله عدد
التشغيل او ما يسمى بالبوتينج او ريستارت
لهذا النظام من جديد لا توجد
افضل توجه لاين من
هاتف خارجيه او داخليه اذا كان هذا
عوف كان متوقعه او لا او هناك هجوم
سيبراني او شيء من هذا القبيل لكن اعتقد
في السعاده القادمه وربما الايام القليله
جدا القادمه عندما تتاكد الوكاله والجهات
التحقيق الاخرى من سبب هذا العطل ربما
سيؤولين عنه بشكل شفاف جدا لكن هذا امر
جدا خطير لانه الاكبر
هو الان على الطائرات التي هي عالقه الان
في الجو ولم تهبط الى الان الى المطاردات
طبعا
صحيح بكل تاكيد لانها تفقد المعلومات
المهمه المتعلقه بالمطارات التي ستهبط
فيها او حتى الطائرات المحيطه بها لذلك
يكون في هذه اللحظات الضغط شديد جدا على
على الاي تي سي او الاير ترافيك كنترولرز
او ضباط الملاحه الجويه الذين هم موجودين
عاده في ابراج المطارات يقدمون المعلومات
المتعلقه بالاتجاهات والارتفاعات
والطائرات المحيطه بكل طائره
فيتم مضاعفه اكيد اعداد هؤلاء في هذه
اللحظات والعمل على مدار الاربعه والعشرين
الساعه بتقديم معلومات اكثر من الطبيعي
يعني هم هؤلاء يقدمون معلومات فقط في
نهايه المطاف الاتجاهات سريعه يعني اليوم
في هذه الاثناء سيقدمون معلومات
العربيه هذه الخريطه بالاقمار الصناعيه
والتي تحجز كثافه كبيره في همم همم
التحليق الطيران فوق الولايات المتحده في
هذه اللحظات مما يضاعف المخاطر التي تحدثت
عنها بالتاكيد سيدي ايهاب
بكثافه ابتداء من الساعه الخامسه صباحا
بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي
وبيعني في الخامسه صباحا في كل مطرات
واشنطن بمختلف
التوقيف من الشرق الى الغرب تبدا المطارات
في العام هناك كتب يتوجهون الى اعمالهم
ووظائفهم باستخدام الطائرات والرحلات تكون
عاده همم غير مكلفه ومدفوعه همم التكلفه
من قبل الشركات فلذلك يستخدمها الكثير من
الموظفون همم من الموظفين وبالتالي همم
هناك عشرات الالاف ربما الان عالقين في
الاجواء وايضا في المطارات لا يعرفون مصير
الرحلات التي سيتوجهون بها الى الاماكن
الاخرى يعني هناك بكل تاكيد فوضى في
المطارات الان تاكد بحسب الاخبار العاجله
سيدي ايهاب انه قد تم ابلاغ الرئيس جوبيد
بهذا العقل اذا قد تم الان ابلاغ الرئيس
بالعطله الحاصل في المطارت الامريكيه وسر
ايهاب يعني هل تعتقد ان السلطات الامريكيه
همم متحسبه لمثل هذه الاعطال هل لديها من
الامكانيات حاليا ما يكفي لانقاذ الوضع
همم المساعده في هبوط هذه الطائرات
العالقه بسلام
من المفترض ان هناك دائما يعني خطب بديله
والولايات المتحده هناك يعني لدينا مطارات
لا تقدر اعدادها بقليله يعني
ربما اكثر من 20,000 مطار داخل الولايات
المتحده همم منها مطارات كبيره ومطارات
صغيره طبعا للتدريب ولتعليم قيادات
الطائره لكن من الممكن توجيه عدد كبير من
هذه الطائرات الى مطارات تتحمل هبوط
طائرات الجد الكبير
وهمم التغلب على هذه المشكله الحادثه الان
بالاضافه الى شيء مهم ايضا متعلق بالتقص
ان الطقس عاده في الصباح الباكر في كثير
من الاماكن همم يكون يبتسم بالضباب
بالضبابيه وبالتالي هذا الايضا تحديات
كبيره جدا للطائرات ولا الطيارين ولل همم
ضباط الملاحه الجويه لتوجيه الطائره اذا
كانت المشكله في جميع المطارات الولايات
المتحده فهل يمكن في اعتقادك توجيه هذه
الطائرات الى مطارات اخرى خارج الولايات
المتحده في دول المجاوره مثلا
يتطلب ان تكون الطائره لديها كميات من
الوقود تكفي للقيام بمثل هذه الرحلات
الطويله يعني بمعنى اذا كانت هذه الرحلات
العالقه في الاجواء في قريبه من شمال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الولايات
الشماليه من الممكن اذا تعذر هبوطها داخل
الولايات المتحده ان تقوم بالهبوط في
مطارات في جنوب افريقيا
الابيض الابيض يقول ان يتابع قضيه ايقاف
حركه الطيران ولد دليل على هجوم السيبراني
حتى اللحظه اذا البيت الابيض يؤكد ان
الرئيس يتابع قضيه ايقاف حركه الطيران
ويقول ان لا دليل حتى الان على هجوم
استرالي حتى اللحظه
نعم يعني هذا هذا منطقي يعني البيت الابيض
يعني هذا تعليق منطقي هو فقط يبلغ الجميع
انه على علم بما حدث وان التطورات الاخيره
لا تقول ان هناك هجوم سبراني والنجوم
سبراني عاده لا يتم الكشف عنه في لحظاتها
طالما لم يترك المهاجمون اي علامات خلفهم
في المواقع التي هاجموها سيبرانيا يعني في
كثير من الاحيان يتركون شعارات يتركون
ربما بعض الكلمات الى اخره لكن في هذه
المرحله ما حدث هو عطله بسببه همم اختفت
كل المعلومات والبيانات التي من المفترض
ان تكون موجوده على شاشات الكمبيوتر في
جهاز النوتم همم وبالتالي همم المعلومات
متضاربه الان لكن اعتقد ان همم كل الامور
ما زالت مفتوحه على مصر عليها بمعنى ان اا
احتماليا ان يكون هجوم سوبر سبراني صحيح
من الممكن ان تكون قائمه واحتماليه ان
يكون حدث عطل ثقني او فني في النظام قائمه
ايضا
الان خارطه حركه الملاحه تظهر الخلو
الاجواء الامريكيه من الطائرات هذه الصور
التي نشرت عبر موقع
فلايت رادار نعم هذه الصور اذا نفوق مدينه
نيويورك مشاهدينا وهي خاريطه تظهر حركه
الملاحه او تظهر حركه الملاحه وهي خاليه
الاجواء خاليه اذا من الطيران الامريكي في
هذه اللحظه فوق مدينه نيويورك وكما ذكرنا
المشاهدين ما زالت السلطات تحقق في
اسباب هذا العطل الان مشاهد
طائره الامريكيه في هذا البث المباشر وهي
تحاول الهبوط في احدى المطارات الامريكيه
مشاهدينا هذه الصور مباشره معكم لطائره
امريكيه وهي تهبط في احد المطرات
الامريكيه في هذه اللحظه على الرغم من
الازمه التي تعيشها المطارات الولايات
المتحده حاليا بسبب توقف حركه الملاحه
بسبب عطل في الكمبيوتر الخاص باداره
الطيران متابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور مباشره
لطائره امريكيه بسلام على همم احد
المطارات في الولايات المتحده كما نتابع
ايضا مشاهدينا في الخبر العاجل يوجهها
وزاره النقل باجراء تحقيقات اللازمه بشان
التعطل حركه الطيران ما زال تحقيق
وهذه الصوره التي نشاهدها في القسم الاخر
من الشاشه
للسماء ولايه نيويورك وهي خاليه من حركه
الملاحه تقريبا هناك محاولات لتوجيهات
الطائرات العالقه في الجو للتوجه نحو احد
طائرات والان هذه اول نزول سالم للطائره
امريكيه بعد هذا العطل الذي همم تعاني منه
جميع المطارات الامريكيه طائره همم ركاب
طائر امريكا انت تهبط الان بسلام في احد
المطارات الامريكيه مشاهدينا ورئيس بايدي
يوجه
بيوجه وزاره النقل باجراء التحقيقات
اللازمه بشان تعطل حركه الطيران
كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا
ولايه نيويورك
خالي يا سماءوها مازال خاليه وهناك هدوء
كبير جدا في حركه الملاحه في اجواء مدينه
نيويورك كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا توقفت حركه
الطيران المدني في الولايات المتحده بسبب
عطل تقني وفقما اشارك اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه حيث تم وقف جميع الرحلات في
كافه انحاء البلاد وذلك بتاجيل 760 رحله
داخل وخارج الولايات المتحده والغاء احد
وتسعين رحله هذه طائره اخرى مشاهدينا ايضا
تتوالى
يتوالى هبوط الطائرات اذا اتباعا في
المطارات الامريكيه همم يبدو ان هناك
محاوله جاده لاصلاح هذا العطل الذي اصاب
معظم المطارات الامريكيه وهناك نجاح في
انزال همم بعض الطائرات العالقه بالنجاح
ايضا ان المحاولات كثيره
هذه الطائره الثانيه المشاهدين كما نتابع
الان على شاشه العربيه كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا
همم تم تاجيل 760 رحله داخل وخارج
الولايات المتحده والغاء احدى وتسعين اخرى
وقالت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه لان العمل
جاري على اصلاح الخلل الفني لاستعاده حركه
الطيران اداره الطيران مشاهدينا نجد المره
اخرى قالت انها نسعى للسيطره على عطل فني
في نظام الاشعارات الجويه
وزير المواصلات وجهها بالتحقيق بسبب العطل
الفني بحركه الطيران نشاهد مره اخرى
مشاهدينا هذه الصوره همم
باقمار الصناعيه للاجواء فوق مدينه
نيويورك وتبدو خاليه تقريبا من حركه
الطيران
الطائرات كما نشاهد في هذه الصور هي
متجمعه في احدى مطارات نيويورك وهناك
طائرتان حتى هذه اللحظه رصدناها وهي تهبط
بسلام في احد المطارات في نيويورك
مشاهدينا اداره الطيران ايضا طلب التاخير
كل الرحلات الجويه حتى تساوي الساعه
الرابعه عشر بتوقيت جرينتش على الاقل سوبر
عطل الفني والرئيس بايدي كما ذكرنا
مشاهدينا يتابع قضيه ايقاف حركه الطيران
ولا دليل على هجوم استرالي حتى اللحظه
ورثه العربيه مشاهدينا اشارت الى تعطل
اثنتين 10,000 رحله طيران في الولايات
المتحده بسبب العطل التقني واداره الطيران
الفضاليه تعلق جميع الرحلات الداخليه في
امريكا حتى الساعه الرابعه عشر بتوقيت
جرينتش تبعنا مشاهدينا قبل قليل
هبوط طائرتين بسلام في احدى في احد مطارات
الولايات المتحده وهذه الصوره للاجواء
بالاقمار الصناعيه فوق مدينه نيويورك
وتظهر خلو الاجواء من الطيران ما عدا تجمع
الطائرات باللون الاصفر كما نشاهد على هذه
الشاشه الان في بعض مطارات البلاد او
بطارات المدينه تحديدا مدينه نيويورك
مدينه معكم مشاهدينا مستمرين في متابعه
هذه التغطيه الخاصه بالاحداث في الولايات
المتحده كما ذكرنا توقفت حركه الطيران
المدني في امريكا بسبب عطل تقني وفقا ما
اشارت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه حيث تم
وقف جميل رحلات في كافه انحاء البلاد
بتاجيل 760 رحله داخل وخارج الولايات
المتحده والغاء احده وتسعين اخرى كمان
شويه على الخبر عاجل مراسل العربيه يتحدث
عن تعطل اثناء 10,000 رحله طيران في
الولايات المتحده بسبب هذا العطل التقني
اداره الطيران علي ايضا مشاهدينا قالت ان
العمل جار على اصلاح الخلل الفني لاستعاده
حركه الطيران
واا
ايضا مشاهدينا قالت نسعى للسيطره على عطل
فني في نظام الاشعارات الجويه ووزير
المواصلات الامريكي بحسب مراسله العربيه
وجه بالتحقيق في اسباب العطل الفني في
حركه الطيران اداره الطيران مشاهدينا ايضا
كما ذكرنا تطلب تاخير كل الرحلات الجويه
حتى الساعه الرابعه عشر بتوقيت مشاهد الان
نتابع هذه الصور في مطار شيكاغو
هذه الصور الان مباشره من مطار شيكاغو
وتظهر ايضا الاجواء وهي خالي ايضا من حركه
الطيران حتى اللحظه لكن ربما نشاهد بعد
قليل بعض الطائرات وهي تهبط بسلام كما
شاهدنا في احدى المطارات محافظه الطائرتان
حتى الان اذا الرئيس بايدي مشاهدينا يقول
بامكان الطائرات الهبوط بسلام لكن لا
يمكنها الاقلاع بالصوت العطل التقني
الرئيس الامريكي المشاهدين يصرح بامكانيه
هبوط الطائرات بسلام لكن كما يقول رئيس لا
يمكن لهذه الطائرات او الطائرات المتواجده
في المطار الاقلاع بسبب العطل التقنيه
العضو مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى مراسله
العربيه اريد سليمان ريتا من جديد لديك
انه تم ايقاف الرحلات الجويه الى المطارات
الامريكيه من قبل اداره طيران حتى الساعه
التاسعه والنصب وكما ذكر البيت الابيض
بانه سلامه الطائرات
هذا العطل يسمح للطائرات بالهبوط ولكن لا
يسمح
لضرورات انديه بالاقلاع
الضرورات امنيه ولي سلامه الرحمه لسلامه
الطاقه
خليل المشاهدين الرئيس بايدن همم تحدث عن
امكانيه الهبوط بسلام لجميع الطائرات
العالقه في الجو لكن هناك منع واضح كما
اذا اشارت مراسله العربيه قبل قليل
للطائرات المتواجده في المطارات في
المدارس لا يمكنها الاقلاع بسبب هذا العطل
هناك همم توقف او تاجيل لسبع مئه وستين
رحله داخل اي الولايات المتحده والغاء 91
رحله همم ممارسه العربيه ايضا مشاهدينا
اكدت ان هناك تعطل الاثنين همم 12,000
رحله طيران في الولايات المتحده بسبب هذا
العطل الفني ووزير المواصلات الامريكيه
والجهه بالتحقيق بسبب العطل الفني بحركه
الطيران اا بريتا هل هذه الاعطال تطال
جميع المطارات في الولايات المتحده من
هناك استثناءات
هذه هذا العطل يا عم المطرات خاصه
وتعمل
حوالي 417 رحله جويه مباشره بين
هاتين المدينتين على اساس يومي امم في
المتوسط هناك حوالي
1923 رحله مغادره كل اسبوع
وفي المطارات الامريكيه ايضا
وتنشر الاشاره بانه الرحلات الجويه الان
فوق الولايات المتحده مقارنه بالوقت نفسه
الاسبوع الماضي حوالي 700 رحله جويه اقل
الان يعني هذا العطل همم اوقف بطريقه
كبيره الرحلات الرحلات الطيران حتى يتم
التحقق بسبب هذا العطر الذي حصل وكما ذكرت
من قبل لما بعد الساعه 9:30 توقيت
خبر عاجل الذي نشاهده على شاشه العربيه
توقف تام الحركه الجويه في الولايات
المتحده هناك ايضا خبر عاجل اخر حول رئيس
بين الذي تحدث عن امكانيه الطائرات الهبوط
بسلام لكن لا يمكنها الاقلاع بسبب العطل
التقني همم البيت الابيض مشاهدينا ايضا
تحدث عن انه لا دليل على هجوم السيبراني
استهدف نظام اشعارات الطيران في امريكا
ومراسل العربيه تحدثت عن تعطل 12,000 رحله
طيران في الولايات المتحده بسبب العطل
التقني ريتا شاهدنا قبل قليل بعض الطائرات
وهي تهبط بسلام في احد المطارات هل توفرت
معلومات حول عدد الطائرات التي هبطت بسلام
حتى الان او حتى معلومات عن الطائرات التي
مازالت عليه في الجو حتى هذه اللحظه
معلومات دقيقه همم لا نملك حتى اللحظه
تفاصيل عن الرحلات الجويه المباشره بين
اييه امم اعود واذكر بين نيويورك
حوالي 700 رحله اقل من الوقت نفسه الاسبوع
الماضي كما ذكرنا بانه الرحلات رحلات
طيران يسمح لها بالهبوط ولكن
يؤثر على هذه الرحلات تحديدا الرحلات التي
ستقلع من المطارات الامريكيه
التي عرضناها على شاشه العربيه الان توقف
اذن الحركه الجويه في جميع اجواء الولايات
المتحده يساوي عطل تقنيه غير معروف الان
الرئيس يتحدث عن امكانيه الطائرات الهبوط
بسلام لكن لا يمكنها الاقلاب بسبب العطل
التقني والبيت الابيض مشاهدينا يقول انا
لا دليل على هجوم استهد نظام اشعارات
الطيران في امريكا وتعطل اثني عشر الف
رحله بحسب مراسله العربيه في الولايات
المتحده بسبب العطل التقني اا مشاهدينا
ايضا الرئيس بايدا وجهها وزاره النقل
باجراء التحقيقات اللازمه بشان تعطل حركه
الطيران مدينه معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه
هذه الاحداث في الولايات المتحده حيث
يتوقفت حركه الطيران المدني بسبب عطل
التقني وفقما اشارت اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع
معكم هذه التغطيه عبر شاشه العربيه
للاحداث
والتطورات غير المتعلقه بتوقف حركه
الطيران في مطارات الولايات المتحده بشكل
تام حتى الان حسب الانباء
الاعلام الامريكي وحسب الخبر العاجل الذي
نشاهده الان على الشاشه يقول بان النظام
التشغيل الرحلات الجويه يعود الى العمل
تدريجيا كانت
الطيران او وكاله الطيران الفدراليه
الامريكيه تحدثت او اعلنت عن التوقف تام
الحركه الجويه في مطارات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
الامر الذي
حذف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للقول بانه
يتابع الان ااا هذه هي التطورات وحاله
التوقف لحركه النقل الجوي ولكن الطائرات
حسب ما نشاهده يعني بعض الطائرات تمكنت من
الهبوط بسلام وتابع معكم خارطه الان
المطارات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كما نشاهد الان على همم الشاشه
نتابع معكم ربما في هذه الصوره الاجواء
الخاليه الان من اي حركه للطائرات في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بسبب العطل
الفني الذي كان سببا في ايقاف جميع
الرحلات الجويه اداره الطيران الى
الامريكي قالت بانها طلبت من شركات
الطيران ايقاف كل الرحلات الداخليه حتى
الساعه 9:00 صباحا بتوقيت واش وقالت بان
همم بانها تسعه الى السيطره على هذا العطل
الفني في نظام الاشارات الجويه هذا النظام
هو نظام نتام وهو يزود الطيارين
بالاشعارات التي يحتاجونها لقراءتها قبل
الطيران قبل الاقلاع
نرصد معكم ربما ونتابع معكم اعداد الرحلات
الجويه التي تاثرت بهذا التوقف حتى الان
وهمم نشير همم هنا همم بان هذا العطر
الفني قد اصاب النظام اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه يعرف باسم انه تم و-
المعلومات الاوليه تتحدث عن تاجيل نحو
1162 رحله داخل الولايات المتحده الغاء
مئات الرحلات همم الاخرى همم هذا النظام
هو نظام امريكي يغتصب بالرحلات الجويه لا
يمكن لاي طائره ان تقلع من مدرجها قبل
الحصول على اشعار رسمي من هذا النظام يفيد
بان الطائره
لاستهدافها من قبل اي دوله اخرى ولكي كذلك
لا تتقاطع مع طائره اخرى في نفس الارتفاع
والمسار
الجوي وقد دخل الخدمه في 1947 لم يحدث له
اي عطل ربما حتى الان باستثناء ما حدث في
2000 وواحد في احداث 11 من سبتمبر هذه
الاحداث التي عطلت التيارات
لفتره من الوقت متابع الان مع مراسلتنا من
واشنطن ريتا سليمان هل من جديد
الجديد حتى اللحظه بانه الطيران الشركات
الطيران اييه تسمح للطائرات بالهبوط في
المطارات ولكن ليس بالاقلاع ولكن حتى
اللحظه ليس من الواضح عدد الرحلات الجويه
التي تاثرت حتى هذه الساعه المبكره هنا
بعد شركات طيران قد تكون قادر على العمل
بدون معلومات من النظام والمعروف بس
النظام همم
فكانت همم الطيران ذكرت بانه الفنيون
حاليا يعملون على استعاده النظام ولا يوجد
تقدير محدد للوقت الذي يمكن استعاده
الخدمه همم اداره طيران
الفحوصات تزرع الان التحقق النهائيه همم
لاعاده تشغيل النظام همم وسيتم تقديم
تحديثات متكرره همم مع همم الوقت
صارت الطيران فيدرالي همم
وجهت بايقاف الرحلات الداخليه حتى ما بعد
الساعه 9:00 صباحا بالتوقيت الشرقي للتحقق
من سلامه معلومات الطيران والسلام العامه
بعد عطل التقني الذي اصاب النظام اداره
الطيران الذي يزود الطيارين بالاشعارات
التي يحتاجونها لقراءتها قبل همم الطيران
همم عدد من الرحلات تاثر داخل الولايات
المتحده وخارجها همم ايضا تم الغاء ما
يقرب من حوالي 250 رحله جويه همم وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه تتحدث عن انه عدد من
المطارات خارج الولايات المتحده تقول انه
العمليات مستمره كالعاده همم ما عدا همم
شركات طيران الامريكيه التي ستتاخر حتى
اشعار
يعني الان كل المطارات الولايات المتحده
متوقفه فيها الحركه الجويه اا ريته
اغلبها لكن هناك مطارات ما زالت تعمل
الطائرات الاقلاب
في الولايات المتحده متوقفه تماما الان
همم هذا مؤكد لكيدا
حتى بيان البيت الابيض الذي اكل لانه ليس
هناك
عندها حاله من الراحه بين المسافرين همم
وايضا في الولايات المتحده بشكل عام واصبح
الامر
من ضمن الفريق التقني الذي يحقق بسبب
العقل ويحاول اصلاح العطر
لا دليل حتى الان على اي هجوم سيبراني
لكنها تحدثت عن عطل الفني دون يعني تاكيد
اسباب هذا العقل صحيح
صحيح همم التحقيقات مستمره حتى اللحظه
وايضا الحديث عن اصلاح هذا العطل باسرع
وقت ممكن لهذا السبب تم تاجيل الرحلات الى
ما بعد الساعه 9:00 صباحا بتوقيت الشرقيه
للولايات المتحده
يعني
يعني انباء هذا الخلل ربما هو هذا العطل
في المطارات الامريكيه هل من معلومات حول
ذلك
حياه الراحل للرحلات الجويه عند الساعه
الخامسه صباحا همم تم هناك تاخير تاخيرها
همم دون شرح الاسباب للمسافرين وبدات
الرحلات تبدا من وقتها وتم اا اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه اعلنت وقف همم جميع
الرحلات للتحقق من العصر التقني وكان هناك
اشعار ايضا دي وزاره النقل والمواصلات
الامريكيه التي همم تارع وزير وزير النقل
والمواصلات الامريكيه بالاعلان عن هذا
الخلل همم التقني
ووجه همم بدء التحقيق في الاسباب بدون
اعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل عندها بدا تتكلم
الرحلات الجويه
واعداد المسافرين همم ايضا في المطارات
وخاصه بين مطران مطارات نيويورك انجلوس
وايضا تم اختار البيت الابيض والرئيس
بعيدا بالموضوع بعد
حوالي الساعه كان هناك بيانات انه لا دليل
على هجوم التبراني لهذا العصر التقني وانه
الفريق التقني مستمر بالتحقيقات وايضا
بمحاوله اصلاح العطله التقنيه شكرا
تطورات او معلومات حول هذه
الحادث ينضم الينا من القاهره العبيد سامر
سمير راغب المتخصص في امن المعلومات ولا
من الالكتروني سيد سمير مرحبا بك معي همم
عطل فني مفاجئ لنظام يعمل همم
1947 ما هي احتمالات ان يكون هذا العطل
بسبب همم هجوم صبران
حضرتك الاحتمالات الهجوم السيبراني
الضعيفه بسبب ااا الانظمه دي بتعمل
بشبكه محليه وشبكه متسعه خاصه يعني ما
هياش داخله عبر الشبكه الدوليه فتقدر تدخل
عليها بنوع من انواع حرب السيبرانيه او
الهاكينج او الوسائل المعروفه يعني ان همم
يعني اعلى درجات تامين في العالم اللي هو
الشبكات طيران الحقيقه والانظمه دي بتسمى
انظمه عريقه بتتكلم من 47 حتى لو بيحصل
تحديث بيحصل تحديث بدون تغيير كامل في
النظام
بتبقى اعلى درجات تامين سواء كان في ال-
في الهاردو غير اللي هي الاجهزه
اللي هي ال- ال-
كهرباء اللي بتدخل لها اول شبكات دائما
بيبقى فيها حاجه اسمها
لو وقع خادم سيرفر يبقى فيه سيرفر شغال
سواء كان في قواعد البيانات او في البرامج
في نفس الوقت في نفس اللحظه والتحديث بيتم
يعني في ريال تايم في الوقت الحقيقي
على الشاشه من الرئيس الامريكي اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه لا تعرف سبب العطل حتى
الان انا اريد ان اعود معك الى الثالث
والعشرين من مايو في 2020
في ذلك اليوم قالت وكاله امن النقل
الامريكيه بانها تخطط لاصدار متطلبات
جديده للامن السيبراني لبعض انظمه الطيران
الرئيسيه بعد ان تعرضت العديد من مواقع
المطارات الامريكيه في وقت سابق من ذلك
الاسبوع اللي هجمات منسقه على ما يبدو
لحرمان الخدمه فبالتالي هذا الامر يعني ان
احتمال
احتراقات سبرانيه لهذا النظام احتمالات
وارده وقد تكون يعني اقرب الى الواقعيه
لنظام كان يعمل سنوات طويله دون اي خلل
حدثنا
همم ممكن لكن مش بالطريقه المعتاده ان
احنا نسمع ان هجوم من الصين او روسي
المسافه بعيده ده يتم بحاجه اسمها مان ذا
ميدل يعني شخص
يقدر يوصل الفيزيكاليد بشكل مباشر لاحد
العقد الاتصال او عقد المواصلات او احد
الاطراف الترمس يقدر يحصل بالشكل ده لكن
ده بنتكلم في في في في عمل مخابراتي في
اختراق داخلي مش في احد المطارات اللي
داخله على الشبكه الخاصه شبكه الاتصال
الخاصه
بهذا نوع ودان اقرب اللي كان همم
او مخرب مخرج يعني حتى موجود
في تلك الفتره قالت بان هناك هجمات
الالكترونيه وقعت وتحدثت عن يوم الاثنين
من ذلك الى اسبوع وهمم الزعيم خلالها بان
هناك قراصنه قد يكون معيدين لروسيا نظموا
من هذه الاختراقات لكنها لم تعطل في ذلك
الوقت عمليات المطارات او الوصول الى
المعلومات
هناك هدف لهذه لهؤلاء القراصنه ربما
باستهداف هذا النظام تحديدا
النهل والترافيك
حركه الطيران
الدوليه يعني النظام بيبقى بيعمل امبوتس
موت خلاف بتخرج على الشبكه الدوليه لكن ما
بياخذش منها مدخلات على اتلاف الكنترول
لكن ممكن ياخذ على منظومه الحجز
الالكتروني لشركات السيارات
الفكره الاختراق محاوله الاختراق ممكن
تحصل على مثل كذا لكن على الشبكه نفسها
اللي بتعمل ترافيك كنت
رول ما ينفع بس ينفع من داخل ال- المحيط
بتاع التمدد الشبكه ممكن الوحيد ده يكون
ممتل شبكه اخرى دوله ثانيه ممكن لكن
بالاخير لابد ان يكون يا اما على الواير
نفسه او الداتا لينك نفسه يعني خلاص
اتصلنا نفسها او بالقرب منها يعني ممكن
فيها اجهزه تقدر تعمل جيميل او تعمل اعاقه
مسافه امطار مثلا
همم من همم
سبرانيا يعني هل هي مساله سهله الكشف في
وقت مبكر ام انها تحتاج الى وقت وتحقيقات
ربما عميقه لتاكيد ذلك
لا المفروض بيبان من اول الفحص الاولاني
اشتري سيستم للنظام يعني اللي هم الناس
اللي بتشغل النظام من الفحص الاولاني
هيبان عنده ان فيه حاجه تسرب غريب يعني من
خارج النظام ممكن يبقى فيه تصرف من داخل
النظام بيبان يعني من بدايه الاول فحص
للستم اللي انا قلت لستك هو يعني اجهزه
وبرامج وقواعد بيانات
وشبكات اتصال وهم مشغلين من الاول ف-
فعشان كده انا باميل الفكره من الاول ان
هم قالوا ان فكره ان ال همم الاتاكد
السايبر اتاك او الهجوم السبراني
غير ورده او مستعده فاكيد هو في حاجه في
اللحظوها في اداء السيستم بتقول ان في
حاجه حصلت لانظمه دي معقده جدا في فكره ان
تعود للخدمه مش بالعمليه
البسيطه
لكن يبان من الاول على طول ان في في هاك
وزي ما
فيش عميد سعود اليك لمناقشه الاحتمالات
الاخرى ولكن دعني يرحب الان بضيفي الذي
ينضم الينا من عمان الكابتن يوسف الدعجه
الطيار المدني اهلا بك كابتن يوسف قبل ذلك
اريد فقط ان يشير الى الاخبار العاجله من
البيت الابيض التي تقول بانه اولاد دليل
حتى الان على هجوم سيبراني وراء التعطل
حركات الطيران في امريكا كابتن يوسف مرحبا
بك ما هو هذا النظام الذي تعطل الان واوقف
الحركه حركه النقل الجوي في كل مطارات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ايه مساء الخير لكم
العربيه العربيه الحدث يا سيدي هذا النظام
اللي بيسموه اشعار للطيار وها باللغه
الانجليزيه انه تايمز وهو ليس له دخل
من قريب او بعيد بتحديد مسار الطائره خلال
رحلتها بللي هي عباره عن معلومات لتنبيه
الطيار عن الاخطار خلال الرحله وان مسار
الرحله وعن الاجهزه المتعطله في المطار
المنوي الهبوط اليه
او المطار الاحتياط هذه لا تعرض الطيران
للخطر ولكن انا برايي هي عباره عن عمليه
اشتباهيه افترازيه من وكاله
مديريه الطيران المدني في الامريكيه لربما
ان هنالك عطل اكبر من هذه الاعطال وانا
برايي المتواضع هذه عباره عن داتا هي
عباره عن معلومات تاتي من المطارات ومن
الارصاد الجويه الى الطيار
حتى يكون على بينه عن مسرح
هذا الاشعار يصل الى الطائره او الطياره
صحيح
هو يا سيدي هاي الاشعارات نتلقاها دائما
قبل الرحله وتكون مكتوبه لربما من اشهر
حتى بتكون موجوده ومن ايام ومن اسابيع وهي
لا تعرض حاله الرحله او الرحله خلالها
للخدمه
عن حالات
في امكانيه للتجمد خلال الرحله خلال
الهبوط والاقلاع الاجهزه التوجيهي
المتعطله في المطارات المنويه الهبوط
اليها حتى يستبدلها الطياره اما هي براي
المتواضع هي عمليه اشتباهيه افترازيه وانا
لربما ارجع عمليات الاختراق الشكراني وهي
كما تعلم ما يحدث حول العالم
في عمليه هذا النظام وعلاقته باقلاع
الرحله او الطائره
وهبوطها انا اريد اخذ معك المساله درجه
درجه الان هل يمكن لاي طائره ان تقلع من
المدرج
قبل الحصول على هذا الاشعار او بعد الحصول
عليه بمعنى انه اذا لم يصل هذا الاشعار هل
يمكن لاي طائره ان تقلع حتى نفهم ما يحدث
يعني
من الناحيه التقنيه
لا يوجد اي خطوره عليها نهائيا من ناحيه
تقنيه اما من ناحيه المعلومات
داخل الطائره اذا كانت امنه صح ولا لا
ادخل في الطائره نهائيا خلينا نوضح شغله
واحده هلا لما تيجي الطياره بدها تهبط في
مطار الماء في اجهزه التوجيه للهبوط
بنسميها العائله
دي بي اجهزه التوجيه انا ممكن توجد في
اجهزه توجيه خلال الرحله للطائره ما تعرف
في معظم الطائرات الايام هاي على الجي تي
اس وال جي بي اجنبي
اصلا ولكن هذه تبين ايضا حالات الجو خلال
خلال الرحله معلومات فقط هي عباره عن
معلومات للطيار
خلال الرحله انه يوجد بعض المطبات
الهوائيه او يوجد شغلات ثانيه من الناحيه
التقنيه ومن ناحيه السلامه العامه على
الطائره لا تؤثر عليها من بعيد او قريب هي
عباره عن معلومات فقط تستطيع الطائره ان
تقلع وتخبط بكل سلام اما من الناحيه ال-
ال- ال-
الاشعار
تستطيع الطائره ان تقلها لا يمنعها من
الاقلاع من المدرج انت تؤكد هذا
اؤكد هذا الامر يا سيدي ولكن هذه
المعلومات يجب تكون مع الطيار هذه حاله
اشتباهيه انا برايي حاله اشتباهيه وهو
جميل جدا منهم انهم يعملوها حاله
اشتباك وما حدث ما هو اكبر اللي اكبر من
هذا يا سيدي الله سمح الله ان تتعطل
الايريك كرافت اللي هي همم اللي توجه
الطائرات في السماء لانه بالحاله هذه
الانسان راح يكون ضايع مش عارف حاله وين
رايح مين مين حوالين من فوقين من تحتيه
تعرض عشرات الالوف من الطائرات يعني في
سماء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واذا
لاحظتهما فقط بطلوا اللي الطائرات اللي
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اما
الانترنت ناشيونال اللي متوجهه الى عبر
المحيطات لم تتعطل من الناحيه التقنيه زي
ما حكيت لك قبل شوي لا يوجد اي خطوره
برايي كما يعني حكيت له قبل شوي لا ربما
يكون هنالك احترازي
ولا ربك يد ولك
نه هجوم شيطاني عباره عن تنبيه انه
بامكاننا نعمل اكثر من هيك ومن يستطيع
وبالمناسبه هذا الجهاز بسيط جدا بسيط جدا
اللي هو بعض المعلومات
هو عباره عن داتا يعني المطار هذا بعطيها
شو في عنده مشاكل للمطار الثاني مثلا
خلينا ناخذ على سبيل المثال انا طالع من
واشنطن جلاس طالع لها شيكاغو
الطيار الان في طائره حتى يقلع يعني هل
هناك نظام اخر
لابد من وجوده تمنع الطائره من اقلاعها
بعيدا عن نظام نتوم او نتام عفوا
ايرمن نوتش
هي معلومات للطيار ومعلومات بسيطه جدا لا
تؤثر على سلامتك
انه الشركه بتكون عندها معلومات بامكان
الشركه تستعمل المعلومات السابقه وتخلي
الطياره تطلع فيها
وهبوط الطائره ولا تؤك
ان هذه المعلومات الموجوده في كتيب صغير
او شيء صغير لا تؤثر على سلامه الطائره
من واشنطن ممم من محيط البيت الابيض ربما
حسب ما وردنا عن اقلاع طائره الرئيس
الامريكي
الذي يتابع الطائره المروحيه التي نشاهد
الان على الشاشه الذي يتابع ما يحدث الان
وحاله التوقف التام للحركه الجويه في
مطارات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اخر تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
الذي وجه بالتحقيق فيما يحدث بانه لا ادله
حتى الان مؤكده على حدوث اي اختراق في همم
في هذا النظام همم
وعلى اي هجوم سبراني ربما يكون وراء
التعطل حركه الطيران في امريكا
الان ارحب بضيفي من دبي الذي انضم الينا
الخبير التقني عبد الله السبع مرحبا عبد
الله تتابع الان هذه الحاله المفاجاه ربما
للمطارات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي توقفت بسبب عطل عطل اللام معلومات
مؤكده حول اسبابه واريد ان اطرح ربما ذات
السؤال يعني ما هي احتمالات ان يكون هذا
العطر نتيجته هجوم سبراني عبد الله
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه يبدون المطارات
الامريكيه خلال الفتره الحاليه موعوده
باحداث جدا كبيره للسنه الماضيه كانت في
مشاكل في هبوط بعض الطيارات بسبب الفاي اف
جي والان عندك مشاكل متعلقه بالانظمه
وغيرها بخصوص موضوع اختراق امس براني او
هجوم امس سبراني هذا امر غير مستبعد لكنه
حسب التوضيحات اللي طلعت منهم انه هو مو
هجوم
لا دليل على اي رجوله
لكنه من الواضح انه بالامكان انه يكون
هجوم سبراني لازم نعرف حتى لو كان النظام
محصن وغيرها همم مع انه هجمات مع تطور
الانظمه مع تطور طرق همم القرصنه قاعد
تكون في طرق مختلفه لقرصه للقرصنه او ايضا
مع تطور الهندسه الاجتماعيه صار من السهل
اختراق بعض الانظمه فعل سبيل المثال السنه
الماضيه حصل اختراق التويتر همم ونشر
تغريدات في حسابات مختلفه كان هذا مقتراق
منصه انما همم هندسه اجتماعيه واختراق
الحسابات احد الموظفين وبعدها تم نشر او
اختراق لوحه التحكم ونشر مثل هذه
التغريدات التي كانت تدعي تقديم عملاء
نقديه للمستخدمين وتم اختراق بياناتهم
وسرقه بعض اموال المستخدمين اجمالا لا
نستطيع نفي همم حاله الهجوم السمراني او
اختراق السبراني نهائيا انما هي تكون
دائما في الاول بسبب التطور التقنيه اللي
حاصل
للسنوات الماضيه حتى ان تطور الامن
السيبراني لا زال الموظف او او الشخص
المسؤول عن النظام هو الحلقه الاضعف حاليا
لاستهداف الانظمه واختراقا طيب مثل هذا
النظام يعني هل من السهل اختراق لانه كمان
انا ودي ارجع الى ما قالته يعني في همم
وكاله الامن امن النقله الامريكي بانها
تخطط لاصدار متطلبات جديده للامن السبراني
لبعض انظمه الطيران الرئيسي عبد الله يعني
انه قد يبدو انه كان لديها معلومات او
حالات وقعت له هجمات الالكترونيه على هذا
النظام
وغيرها وهمم ادى الى مطالبه الشركه في تلك
الفتره او الاداره بالتحديث متطلبات الامن
السيبراني لهذه الانظمه
شوف ما في شيء نقدر نقول ان مستحيل اتوقع
انهم قاعدين يحاولون ينفون ان ال موضوع
الاختراق السبراني بكل الطرق خوفا من
عواقب اخرى لكن لازم نعرف معلومه مجال
الطيران يعتبر واحد من اامن المجالات في
النقل فذلك في اشتراطات جدا صارمه في
الطيران وغيرها لذلك قد يكون خلل بسيط هو
اللي يساهم في ايقافه
اللي ممكن يحدث هذا العطل عبد الله
ما نقدر نعرف بالضبط لانه حتى الان ما في
تفاصيل واضحه منهم لكن لازم نعرف ان
الاشتراطات الطيران او اشتراطات السلامه
للطيران دائما تصعب من عمليه الطيران في
حال وجود اي مشكله فلذلك من الواضح ان
النظام وتعطله ادى الى تاخير عدد كبير من
رحلات زي ما واضح قدامكم
الان ينضم الينا حسين الطود مراسل العربيه
من احد مطارات من مطار واشنطن تحديدا اهو
رونالدو حسين مرحبا
في المطار مع التوقف حركه الطيران بشكل
انسان
تحيه لك خالد بالفعل انا هنا في مطار
رونالدو القريب المحاذي للعاصمه واشنطن
اييه هناك طبعا حاله من الارباك من
الارتباك المسافرون هنا
مصدومون بها بما جرى جميع الطائرات الان
المتوقفه عن الاقلاع ولكن هيئه اداره
الطيارات الطيران الامريكي قالت انه هناك
استعاده لاستعاده عمل النظام اشعارات حركه
الطيران يبدو ان الامور تتجه
همم
يثبت او لم يتحدث
انه لا يوجد هناك معلومات دقيقه حول ذلك
همم ما يجري حتى تكهنات لكن يجب ان نذكر
بانه في شهر اكتوبر الماضي تعرضت همم نحو
اربعه او خمس مطارات امريكيه لهجوم سيدنا
وجدت اصابع الاتهام الى روسيا ولكن الان
حتى الان نتمنى اي هيئه ولا تتمنى اي جهه
مسؤوله هنا في الولايات المتحده وقوع
الحديث عنه هو عطل فني في احد الاجهزه
التي تم اعاده تنزيلها على الخوادم
بتشغيلها مره اخرى هذه تقريبا معظم
المعلومات التي لدينا الان ولكن المذكرها
مره اخرى انه في شهر مارس الماضي ااا من
العام الماضي كان هناك تحذيرات حتى من
الرئيس الامريكي لنفسه يومها بانها البنيه
التحتيه الامريكيه وال- اا
بنينيه قد تتعرض لهجوم سييبراني ويوم طلب
مشغلين ومالكيه همم البنيه التحتيه مثل اي
دبليو
مايكروسوفت وجوجل بان يحسنوا من جوده ولكن
حتى الان لا يوجد
توجيه التهام بحدوث عمل سيبراني ما يتم
الحديث عنه حتى الان هو عطل خالد
المعلومات حول المطارات التي بدات فيها
بحسب المعلومات التي توصلنا بها هي لم
تبدا بجميع المطارات فكان هناك بعض
المطارات حتى لو بعد شركات الطيران استمرت
بعملها ولكن مع تقريبا مع السادسه والنصف
او السابعه تم توجيه ااا طلب امر لجميع
حركات او شركات الطيران
اقلاع الطائرات وخالات السماء الامريكيه
من وجود اي طائره تقريبا الان هناك حديث
على انه العطس كما قلنا بدا يتم همم هل
المشكله وستبدا عمليه الطيران تدريجيا في
الساعات المقبله حتى التاسعه يجب ان يكون
هناك همم
حركه الطائرات متوقفه حتى التاسعه صباحا
بتوقيت مباشره بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي
الساعه الثانيه ظهرا بتوقيت جرينتش وطبعا
هذه توقف الحركه هنا اثر كما سمعنا حتى
على حركه الطيران العالمي في اوروبا واسيا
وافريقيا
طب عدد الرحلات التي تاثرت الكل في ربما
او الاثمان ااا لهذا التاخير هل يمكن
رصدها او على الاقل قراءتها حسين
التوقعطيل ل 1200 رحله تعطلت يعني اخذ
تاجل اقلاعها
ولكن كم عدد الرحلات التي فهمنا بانه تم
توقيف جميع الرحلات لم تفطر اي طائره تقلع
اي طائره من المدرجات في الساعات القريه
الماضيه وسيبها الحال على على الوضع على
حاله حتى الساعه الثانيه ظهرا بتوقيت
جرينتش التكلفه طبعا ستكون هناك خسائر
كبيره لا يمكننا الان احصاءه وتقديرها
ولكن همم دائما عندما يكون هناك تاخير
اقلاع الطائرات وهمم والغاء الرحلات هناك
همم تامين وهناك دفع او بيضات وهنا
المسافر ان يلغي رحلته لانها تاخرت على
الشركه ان تعوده هناك طبعا رقم لا يمكن
تحديده الان مباشره ولا كان يتشاف في
الساعات الله يحفظكم بما في الايام
القادمه
ما ابتدابير التي تتخذ الان من قبل شركات
الطيران في التعامل مع حاله الالغاء او
تاجيل بالنسبه للمسافرين همم التي اشارت
اليها يمكن بشكل
قصه توليد بعض التفاصيل فيما تراها
عندما يتم الغاء رحله او همم تاجيل رحله
القانون الفيدرالي يلزم الشركات بتعويض
المسافرين اذا طبعا اذا كان ال الغاء هو
بسبب عطل في همم فني لدى الشركه او بسبب
همم مثلا مثلا وجود عاصفه همم تمنع
الرحلات كما حدث همم سابقا في العاصفه
التي ضربت باقله او يحدث عصير التي تضرب
جنبها الولايات المتحده عند اذن على
الشركات تتقبل بانها ستعود او بانها على
الاقل ستعطي فرصه للمسافر لتعطيه مثلا اذا
لم ااا لم تكن همم قوانينها الداخليه تسمح
باعاده الاموال لانه قبل بعض الاوقات وهذه
حدثت معنا همم عندما تشتري تكت- تذكره
طائره لتذهب الى مكان وتضربه ويضربه
الاعصار من حقق ان لا تذهب من حققا طالب
بتعويض ولكن هم ما تعويض يضحكون على شكل
كريدت لكي تسافر به ااه في وقت لاحق هذا
قانون في دلاله يلزم الشركات الامريكيه
لذلك وهمم هذا هو الاشياء المتبعه بالنسبه
اذا تم الغاء كل شيء بسبب بقى همم عاصفه
او بسبب هجوم سيبراني همم ربما ربما يعني
ليست معلومات دقيقه ولكن ربما يكون هناك
همم نوع اخر من التاجيل همم المتعلق بدفع
ال- ال- همم
تعويضات للمسافرين لانه ايضا ليس ذنب
الشركه لتقوم لتفعل لكي تعوض ليس دمها
هناك هجوم سايدراني هناك عاصفه ضربت
المنطقه وهجوم ارهابي ولكن بطبيعه الحال
دائما التركيز في الولايات المتحده ايضا
على
الزبون بالحصول على تعويضاته وبه حمايته
من كما يقال يعني من الشركات الكبرى اداره
الطيران الفيدرالي تكون الان بان هناك
تقدم في استعاده عمل النظام الشعارات حركه
همم
تحديدا همم بانه يتم استئناف حركه الطيران
بشكل تدريجي في مطار اتلانتا وهمم يورك
هل ترصد او ترى
باي حركه على استعاده العمل همم لديك الان
في مطار الحسين
هو مطار صغير مطار شيكاغو ومطار همم
في جورجيا ومطار سان فرانسيس وهذه مطارات
همم مطارات كبيره
طائرات وشركات طيران كبيره حتى مطار بلتي
مور في همم هذه بشكل اساسي بالعطاء الكبرى
وهي التي كانت اصلا همم في شهر اكتوبر من
العام الماضي بالهجوم طيب رانيا الذي ضرب
كما قلنا اربعه الى خمس مطارات اوروبا
وهناك حديث عن ست مطارات المطارات الصغيره
مثل مطار رونا دراجون هو مطار وطني كي
يكون هناك في رحلات داخليه داخل الولايات
المتحده هناك رحله من هذا المطار اعرف
برجانها موجوده انا هو كندا هي هذه ربما
هذه الرحله الوحيده خارج الولايات المتحده
همم معظم الرحلات التي تضار من هنا يا
رحلات وطنيه طبيعه الحال هناك تاثير هناك
تعبتم همم حركه الطيران لهذا هذا الان على
مستوى وطني همم اداره طيران الفيدراليه
الامريكيه طلبت من جميع الشركات الطيران
لا تقلع طائراتها عن المدارس لذلك همم كما
اشاهد الان هنا على المدرسه همم الطائرات
المتوقفه ولكن همم
ولكن همم بطبيعه الحال كما قالوا انها
الساعه التاسعه بعد نحو همم ثلث ساعه من
الان ستبدا الحركه تدريجيا بالعوده حتى
يتاكد من انه لا يوجد يؤثر على سلامه
المسافرين ويؤثر على سلامه همم حركه
الطيران همم هنا في الولايات المتحده
اريد فقط نشير الى ما نشاهده الكذلك على
الشاشه احد همم في واشنطن احد المطارات
متوقفه في الحركه تماما في نيويورك الامر
كذلك وكذلك في شيكاغو واشير الى ما جاء في
واشنطن بوست بان انباء هذا الخلل كانت
بدات عندما تحدث بعض الركاب على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي عن التاخيرات في
الرحلات وانقطاع في جميع انحاء الولايات
المتحده منهاواي الى واشنطن من تكساس الى
بن سلفانيا بعد ذلك تم اا اعلان توقف
الرحلات الجويه بشكل مؤكد في جميع انحاء
البلاد
ونشير ايضا هنا الى تصريحات البيت الابيض
لا دليل حتى الان على هجوم سيبراني وراء
تعبدوا الحركه الطيران في امريكا لا ادري
اذا كان همم الحسين ما زال ما حسين حسين
حسين
الصوت يتقطع
هي المساله فقط عن مساله اذا كان هذا
الخلل في هذا النظام همم يمنع
الطائرات من الاقلاع او الهبوط
المسافرين هذا هو سبب ربما تستطيع طائره
ان تقلع حسب ما قرات هي لم تكن همم تصيب
جميعا شركات الطيران وليست كل المطارات
ولكن تجنبا لحدوث وقوع حوادث تم هذا
القرار على مستوى وطني وتم منع جميع شركات
الطيران من اقلاع تايراتها عن المدارس همم
لانه بحسب الخبر هناك بعض الشركات بدا
كانت تعمل خلال همم
تعطل شركات اخرى كان هناك عدد من الشركات
في عدد من المطارات تعمل ولكن هذا اجراء
اجراء سلامه همم يتخذه المسؤولون
الامريكيون لدار اي مخاطر قد تحدث وهم اا
في غفله من امرهم يبحثون عن حل مشكله ما
في مطار الماء ولشركه ما سيكون هناك مشكله
اكبر في مكان اخر همم يكون الثمن بعد عن
همم رحلات جويه يعني اي خلل في اي طائره
تكون لا قدر الله كارثه كبرى في اي دوله
ليست فقط في الولايات المتحده
ساعود اليك ذكاء اذا استجدد في معلومات
شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان الحسين الطود
مراسل العربيه
الى العميد سمير راغب المتخصص في اامن
الالكتروني والمعلومات
سيد عميد سمير يعني هل يمكن ان تعلق اذا
كان لك اي رؤيه الان ربما استجددت في ضوء
المعلومات المتوفره
من عمان لفرق ما بين الداتا الجلوبال
يعني طياره طبيعي بالاجهزه بتستقبل
قويه اتجاه الريح سرعه الرياح الكلام ده
بيوصله لغايه المطار اول ما يتم الترافق
كنترول بيبتدي يدي له الداتا بتاعته اللي
هي الظروف اللي الطياره هتنزل فيها على
الممر وهتقف فيها اكثرمك بيقول له اتجاه
الريحه قد ايه سرعه الريحه قد ايه يبقى
الاجهزه اللي شغاله المساعده الفلاح
على طول مطرات صغيره مش مطارات بتستقبل
عدد ضغط طيب في طيارات نزلت رغم الظروف دي
دائما ال- ال- همم
فرم المراسل بيقول بتتم مانولي يعني بيدي
له عن طريق جهاز اللاسلكي الداتا اللي
المفروض توصل له على الجهاز فما بيقدرش
يعمل ده مع عدد كبير من الطيران بدليل ان
في طيارات الخارجيه نزلت ووقفت طيران
الداخلي وقفه الطيران الداخلي عشان الاهلي
عشان مش هيقدر بشكل يدوي اولي يشتغل
باللاسلكي مع كل الطيارات اللي بتنزل
اعداد ضخمه جدا وده اللي خلى شركات
استهبلت التابلت هل خلفت السلامه لم تخالف
السلامه ابتدا يشتغل زي ما كان بيشتغل قبل
الكمبيوتر
بالاسلكي بيقول له سرعه الرياح كذا الجهاز
الفولاني شغال مش الجهاز الكلام ده ادي له
الداتا ان من اجهزه القياس الموجوده عنده
في المطار
اللي بتدينا وممكن حد فينا يدخل على النت
يجيبها دي ما بتسالش ال- غير ان التيار
توصل لا بروتشي اللي هي بتبتدي الكنترول
بيوجهه على الممر الفلاني وسرعه الريح كذا
لان ممكن بسرعه تتغير والتيار بينزل ف- اا
اساس الموضوع فكره ال- ال- التعادل النظام
استعاده النظام بتاخذ وقت احنا نتكلم
على حاجه يعني المستودعانات
همم العمل نتيجه اختراقه وعمل اا عدائي
همم يعني من اي كان من اي جهه ما هي
الاسباب التي الاخرى التي قد تسبب مثل هذا
العطل الان
همم
بالالكتروني ده عرضه ان هو يعطى لكن بيبقى
الاعتماديه بتاعته عاليه
بتوصل يعني
99.4 ساعات يعني احتمال العطل مثلا واحد
في في في في المليون او واحد في الميدان
فبيت لكن احتمال العطله وارد
ما هي الاسباب لا يعطل بعيدا عن الاختراق
السبران او القارئ
في النظام
يعني بيستقبل
الحركه همم
بتخش على على النظام النظام فيه البرامج
وفي قواعد البيانات قواعد البيانات ممكن
يحصل او سقوط لقاعده البنات الوصله
فيها فيها مشكله
هذه ما هي ما الذي يمكن ان يسبب هذه
المشكله غير غير اي اختراق من ناحيه تقنيه
يا سيدي
اه اه
حصل فيه مشكله زي ما قلت سيادتك
المشكله مثل الماده التي المشكله التي قد
تحدث للنظام للداتا غير الاختراق
الخادم نفسه اللي هو قواعد البيانات هي
كمبيوتر زي برده لو لو كمبيوتر منه
معالجات حصل فيها عطل هتوقف ان قاعده
البيانات
بقاعده البيانات لما تقف خلاص السموات لو
سوفت وير حصل فيه مشكله داخل الانظمه
التشغيل او البرامج اللي متحملها على
انظمه التسجيل تشغيل ف هيحصل مشكله لو حصل
في في في اللوكالوريا
جوه الخادم الرئيس حصل فيها
اتقطع حسب تيشرت شركه
في التشغيل بتاخد وقت من ان هو ما هواش بي
تي زي اللي في البيت ده احنا بنتكلم على
يعني السيرفر
احتمال احتمال اللي هي الحمل الزائد على
الخوائد من الاوفرلود همم كاحتمال اول
ربما اذا همم اذا حدد ذلك هل مساله
استعاده التشغيل يعني تاخذ وقت طويل او
بالامكان اعاده بشكل سريع اذا كانت اذا
كان السبب هو الحمل الزائد على الخواتم
يعني
بشغل النظام كهاردوير
ويبتدي لو لو الاوفر لود حصل يبتدي يزود
همم
برهان بيزود
المساحات النهارده بيفك ممكن النهارده همم
ديسك يحصل فيه حاجه اسمها بادكتور يبتدي
النهار ده الديسك ده يغيرها او طبعا انا
بابسط يعني هو طبعا
همم بعد همم يحل المشكله نفسها بيروح عامل
رجليكا يعني بيشوف في القاعده بيانات
سليمه يروح عامل باقه للبيانات ثاني وبعد
كده يبتدي بيشغل السيستم ب- بيشغله اوف
لاين يعني الداخلي يتاكد ان السيستم
استيبل السيستم مستقر يبتدي يعمل فري
فايلز الداتا يبتدي يشوف قداده الجديده
اللي بتوصل له
همم
تعمل فيه مطارات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني منذ بدء همم ادخاله للخدمه
يعني حتى الان ممكن يكون هذا سبب يعني
منطقي محتمل في دوله امريكا يعني يؤدي الى
التوقف الحركه
اريد ان اذهب الى الان الى الى البيت
الابيض و كلمه الرئيس الامريكي
كلمه واحده ربما رد بها الرئيس الامريكي
الان في سؤال عن اسباب هذا العطل قال لا
اعلم ايضا والتوجه الى طائرته المروحيه
كما نرى الان في متابعه لهذا الحدث الذي
الان يشل كل مطارات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه همم اخر المعلومات
التي
وردت حتى الان بان هناك بعض المطارات التي
عادت للعمل تدريجيا لكن الرئيس الامريكي
الان يجيب لا نعرف في رده على سؤال حول
اسباب تعطل حركه الطيران ما رايك عميد
سمير
في الخادم الرئيس السيسي
يعني في المنشر اللي هو بيغذي الكل
فبالتالي ما حصلش فكره مطار او اثنين
تعرضوا لهدوم سبراني نتكلم على الخادم
الرئيسي اللي باقي باقي المطارات ترمز
يعني هي بتلقى منه وتبعته يعني يعني
بتهندر هاكت معه لكن ما عندهاش داتا داتا
بتجيء لها منه
وتوزعها للطيارات اللي في حياتها لكن
الموضوع في سيستم موضوع النظام القديم
همم ده احد الانظمه المعروفه ومشاكلها
بتبقى في فكره انك انت بتعمل صيانه وتحديث
بسفينه اثناء البحار يعني ما تقدرش تقف
النظام لان في طيارات بتشتغل طيب يبقى
عمليه التطور ممكن تلاقي فيه انظمه قديمه
مثلا
ضبط قاعه بيانات قديمه لان فكره ترجح بس
حتى اخذ راي ضيفه الخلفيه هذه التغطيه
الترجيحتك ماذا او توقعاتك
الهجوم السيبراني
للي يعني
تكنيك مش صعب جدا لان اولا مؤمنه ثانيا
معزوله عن فكره
اخرى يعني تقبل شهرين وحتى العام الماضي
يا عميد سمير خليني اروح الى عمان الى
الكابتن يوسف الدعجه يعني احتمالات وارد
لانه هناك احدا اتوقعت همم
اه طيب حضرتك الاولى الاحتمال وارد
لك هيحصل ازاي لما تحدث اختراقات فبالتالي
هناك شكوك او تساؤلات حول مدى حمايه او
تامين هذه الانظمه همم عميد سمير همم
كابتن يوسف
هلكت تعليق حول هذه التطورات
شغله مهمه جدا بالنسبه
للمطار
ليس له اي دخل لا من بعيد او من قريب
بسلامه
الطائره تعتمد على المعلومات السابقه على
سبيل المثال لما تكون في
عندكها الكلام
فقط سعودي
نعم واسلام
[موسيقى]
حول السبب هذا التعطل
بانهم لا يعرفون حتى
الاجواء الامريكي
سلام لكن طبعا كما شاهدنا ايضا في الصور
وحسب كل المعلومات المتوفره ان همم الحركه
الطيران او ربما الاقلاع ما زالت متوقف
حتى اعود الى الكابتن يوسف تفضل
[موسيقى]
بديش اقول انا متاكد ولكن احتماليه كبيره
انه هجوم شيفراني الجهاز بسيط جدا
والجهاز او المعلومات
هي عباره عن معلومات لا تؤثر لا من بعيد
ولا من قريب على سلامه الطائره
اذا كان هذا الامر صحيح
من الحكومه الامريكيه لربما يكون هنالك
هجوم اكبر من هذا بحيث طلع حركه الطائرات
في السماء يحطل حركه الاي تي سي الاغراض
الكنترولرز توجيه الطائرات وهو هذا المهم
انه تيمز والاي تي سي والحاله الجو بان
كانت تستقيها خلال الرحله من اي محطه انت
تشاء ولكن توجيه الطائرات اللي هو الاي تي
سي الارتراف كنترولر هذا هو المهم والم
يم معهم موجود
بحيث يستطيع ان يراقب الطائرات
360 درجه حول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الشغله هي عباره عن
المعلومات من المين كنترول التي التي
تذكرها يعني
لا يا سيدي ما لها دخل بالطيران هاي
معلومات بسيطه جدا نستقيها اللي هي النوت
انه المشكله قد تتجاوز الى الى همم من
كنترول
صح ولا لا اذا كنت فهمت كلامك
من هناك طيارين يعني في اقلاعكم وهبوطكم
ام ماذا
الطيران من عمان
غرب شمال
ليس له علاقه نهائيه
ان يتم
ان ان يمتد الخلل الى هذا النظام الذي
يمدكم بالمعلومات ما بعد الاقلاع
ير
الى
360 درجه الى
340 درجه تحت
30 درجه لنفرض وهذا الجهاز التوجيهي اللي
هو الرادارت عطل
ورح اسوي انا انا ما عندي شيء حتى
ترمات
[موسيقى]
وكان في اقلاع وهبوط عشرات البنيئات من
الطائرات موجوده هون الخوف الخوف ليس من
النوتانز هو عباره عن جريعه
مع بسيطه جدا
وانه لا يوجد لان الجهاز بسيط جدا ليس
بحاجه انه ولا يؤثر على سلامتك
الجويه على مستوى البلاد كابتن هذا يعني
انه خلاص انت المشكله في ما يتعلق بانه
تارس
هي عباره عن تاكدوا انهم سيطروا على هذا
وراح تبين من الايام تاكدوا انهم سيطروا
على هذا الفايروس او بغض النظر ايش ما كان
يكون
لان الهجوم على الرادارات منين الرادارات
اللي موجوده التي تتحكم في حركه الطائرات
حول العالم حتى في المحيط الاطلسي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه رقم ح
ركه حتى اي شيء وما بدي اتعدى اكثر من هيك
يعني لدرجه ان الذبابه لا تستطيع ان تخترق
المجال الجوي الامريكي
جماعه الخير اخطر بكثير الهجوم على شبكه
اللوكانوس
بدء حركه همم طائرات بدا ربما تدريج
لاقلاع بعض الطائرات نشاهد بعد الطائرات
في الاجواء الامريكيه لانها تحديدا في اي
منطقه بالضبط لكن هناك مجموعه طائره بدات
ربما انت كمان نشاهد الان وقت من المطارات
التي اعلن بانها عاده تدريجيا الان الحركه
همم فيها نتابع التطورات والمعلومات اولا
باول الان كما نشاهد الى ان هذه الحركه
لبعض الطائرات كذلك في مطار نيويورك همم
واحد مطار نيويورك اداره الطيران في
العاجل تسمح باقلاع الرحلات الجويه على
مستوى البلاد في دلاله ربما لمعالجه همم
الخلل هذا العطل الفني الذي اصاب
النظامز همم سريعا كابتن يوسف تقديرك لحجم
الخسائر والتكلفه من وراء هذا التوقف اللي
حركه الطيران في كل المطارات الامريكيه
سريعا
رات
مئات الملايين الدولارات
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
لك من عمان اذا الكابتن يوسف الدرج الطيار
المدني كان معنا ايضا في هذه التغطيه عمي
سمير راغب المتخصص في الامن الالكتروني
وامن همم المعلومات
المدكر فقط لاخر التطورات في هذا الحادث
بان هناك عطلان فنيا كان قد سبب تعطل وشلل
في حركه الطائرات والمطارات والولايات
المتحده همم الامريكيه توقفت بموجب
جميع الرحلات الجويه اخر تصريحات الرئيس
الامريكي الذي سال عن اسباب ذلك قلب انهم
لا يعلمون حتى الان اداره الطيران
الفيدرالي وكما تابعنا ايضا في احد
المطارات في نيويورك تسمع
بعوده تدريجيه لحركه همم الطيران في بعض
مطارات الولايات المتحده تغطيه نايدا
مستمره نذهب الى الزميل ميسون اعز من دبي
انا اودعكم